[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
a mother accused of murdering her
six-year-old son then dumping his body
in the ohio river
her sister now speaking out about
possible warning signs
he would light up a room when he would
walk into one
he was very known for giving his big
hugs defense attorneys for the former
michigan governor
charged in the flint water crisis want
his case dismissed
why the special prosecutor is saying not
so fast
we seem to be kind of going off the
rails here and
on assault caught on camera your sneak
peek into the new hit show
i survived a crime plus the allegations
of sexual harassment that could mean
legal trouble for new york's governor
andrew como long crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
an ohio woman is in jail accused of
killing her six-year-old son
and dumping his body in a river lawn
crimes anjanet levy is here with the
disturbing details of the case
yeah brian police in middletown ohio say
that britney gauzy and her boyfriend
initially tried to say that her son
james hutchinson was missing but that
story
quickly began to unravel and now both of
them are facing charges
james was a sweet loving caring little
boy
heather ghazny can't help but cry when
she thinks about what happened to her
six-year-old nephew
james he was very known for giving his
big hugs he loved hugging people
showing everybody love gosney says she
last spoke to her
sister brittany on january 26th brittany
called me
trying to get me to take the kids
because her boyfriend was trying to make
her get rid of the kids
brittany did not want to sign custody
over to me fast forward to last
friday night police say james died when
his mother tried to leave him and his
siblings at a state park
because her boyfriend james hamilton
wanted her to get rid of her four
children
an incident report states that james
grabbed onto the door handle of his
mom's van when she tried to leave
and then brittany gosney slammed on the
gas dragging james and possibly running
him over
police say gosney and hamilton dumped
james's body into the ohio river
early sunday morning at the ohio indiana
state line
and then reported him missing law
enforcement and volunteers spent the day
sunday
searching on the ground and from the air
james's family and classmates are
stunned and
sad beyond belief his school brought in
therapy dogs to help the young students
deal with their loss
it's heartbreaking and i don't
understand it
and i wrote like i said i don't believe
brittany did this i believe her
boyfriend did it
now heather gosney says that recently
her sister brittany had blocked
all of their family members on facebook
so they really hadn't had any contact
with them in the last month or so
brittany gosney is facing charges of
murder abuse of a corpse
and tampering with evidence her
boyfriend james hamilton
faces charges of abuse of a corpse and
tampering with evidence as well he is
not charged with murder
brian we'll send it back to you thanks
ange joining us now with legal analyst
dina dahl along with terry austin
deena the charges are based on ghazni's
statements so far
but the other children involved they
have yet to be interviewed
could we see more charges or even
different charges against the
couple after those interviews
yes very possible that there may be
murder charges brought against the
boyfriend
or at least a conspiracy to commit
murder for both of them
if the boyfriend wasn't actually
actively involved in the murder itself
but that maybe there was an agreement
between them and he did some action
further into the murder because it
appears that the girlfriend said
that she was doing this partly because
of him
right now like they have that kind of
evidence and that's why they haven't
charged them but we often see
a charges being brought later as the
police continue to investigate a case
now terry the more you hear about the
story the more gut-wrenching
it gets ghazi seems to suggest that
hamilton wanted her
to do it but that's not quite coercion
could there be possibly defense here
though
i don't think it's a defense brian
listen for a case like this that could
be an
explanation but it's not a legitimate
defense unless she can show that this
was some sort of self-defense or it was
an accident or to your point
that she did it under duress and she had
no choice
i think a murder charge is definitely
going to prevail and don't forget
this is the state of ohio and this
individual victim
is under the age of 13 so this could be
aggravated murder
which means the mother could possibly
face the death penalty
good point anjanet things like this
typically don't happen in a vacuum
had child services worked with the
family before
yeah brian the police chief said during
a news conference that children's
services had had contact with brittany
ghazni and her children
in the past the children had moved from
hotel to hotel at times during their
lives they had been in and out of the
school district even living
i believe in another state at one time
so there was some contact whether or not
children services was currently involved
we don't know that at this point in time
i should mention though too that
searchers are still actively looking for
little james's body
in and around the ohio river and they'll
continue to do so this weekend if need
be
it's sad that none of those red flags
caught this
tragedy before it happened and we're
always hopeful that
the child's body is found for at least
some sense of closure for the family
thank you all for your input on this
story a new management order
is setting the stage for the first
former minneapolis police officer to go
to trial in the death of george floyd
judge peter cahill made the decision
with coven 19 restrictions in mind for
derrick chauvin's trial
only one member of george floyd's family
and one member of derek shelvin's family
will be allowed in the courtroom both
families will have assigned seats
must wear a mask and must remain six
feet apart from
other people within the courtroom jury
selection for the trial is slated to
start monday march 8th
shogun is facing a second degree murder
and manslaughter charges
the former officer may also face a third
degree charge of murder
pending an appeal be sure to tune in to
the law and crime network for gavel to
gavel coverage
of chauvin's trial still ahead on long
crime daily
the defense for the former governor of
michigan in the flint water crisis case
argues you can't be the judge or jury in
his case
and later on an update in the saga of
lady gaga's stolen french bulldogs
her dog walker's message of recovery
after being shot
stay tuned
[Music]
welcome back a pre-trial hearing for the
former michigan governor charged
in the flint water crisis got heated
during arguments by both sides
rick snyder is facing two counts of
willful neglect of duty
more than 80 people fell sick and 12
died after the city changes drinking
water from a treated source to the flint
river in 2014.
snyder's defense is asking for the
charges to be dismissed saying in court
documents
that neglecting a city isn't a crime
prosecutors are upset over a letter the
defense filed the night before snyder's
hearing
requesting flint residents to not be
allowed to serve as the judge
and jurors in his trial the defense says
flint residents could benefit
from a 600 million dollar settlement
if in fact council believes that
you know now he would like to file this
motion to disqualify the court
which he didn't file before and if he
believes
that's a decision that needs to be made
before further rulings
then there should be a request of the
court
to uh you know change the order in which
the rulings are made
that's fine but we on behalf of the
people we really insist
on doing this the way court cases are
done
according to the rules with an
opportunity to respond
in writing and argue matters not simply
grandstand and hurl accusations in
emails to the court
assistant attorney general ketler said
today they want this handle
like tip other cases are typically
handled
she all she also said last week that
um as much as humanly possible they want
this done in the light of day
well that's not true if they were so
confident that their
venue motion was accurate that it was
venue then they could dismiss
and bring this case in genesee county
and then the only issue before this
court would be improper venue
when they decided not to do that to use
the one judge grand jury
instead of going and filing in a
district court like thousands of other
cases they want it handled like other
cases
that's the way to do it but by doing
that your honor
they not only have refused to identify
who the witnesses
are that's not like they typically
handle cases they're usually right on
the complaint
they didn't haven't given us any
evidence of governor snyder's guilt
and then had they done that
then then it would be handled like a
typical case
so it's absolutely patently and
objectively false
to say that the people want this done in
the daylight and handled like regular
motions
the judge then jumped in as referee
until both sides they'll have the
opportunity to argue their motions in a
hearing
next week we definitely
want to handle this case as much as
possible
like every other misdemeanor case
but it's clear from the outset this case
is not like any other
misdemeanor case this whole grand jury
process is fascinating to me it's done
largely in secret
know little about it as a person a
citizen
an attorney or even as a judge and i've
been given a good education on this
but as far as i'm concerned right now
there's one motion
before the court we have a scheduled
hearing on it
and that's how i would proceed i
understand why there might be
other emotions that somebody might wish
to bring or not bring or whatever that's
that's not my job back to discuss the
hot water rick snyder has found himself
in
is legal analyst dina dahl and co-host
terry austin terry
no judge or jury from flint because they
are alleged victims i mean
on its face it kind of makes sense do
you think this case could be moved to a
neighboring county then
i do brian and i think that the governor
while i want him to be held accountable
for his actions
he has a very good point under the sixth
amendment as we all know
you are entitled to an impartial jury
and so theoretically if the case is
tried
with flint residents then theoretically
they could be jurors who were actually
harmed by
these actions so i think it should
either be moved
to another county or i do think that
maybe they should
remove flint residents from the jury or
grand jury so
if i were prosecuting the case frankly i
would actually agree
to move it so you don't have any issues
as far as an appeal might be concerned
yeah you want that conviction if you're
looking for it to be final dina
dismissal because neglecting a city
isn't a crime that's a creative argument
but how do you think it's going to be
panning out for the defense
i don't think they're going to win that
motion here because it is
under the penal code wilfa neglect of
duty is a misdemeanor which he was
charged in
so it's it's clear that it is a crime
i think though that that argument might
do better if he's convicted
on appeal because this is a first
impression case you've never had a
governor
be you know charged with a misdemeanor
this misdemeanor crime
and there could be an argument that this
wasn't the intent of the statute this
statue wasn't applied correctly to him
that's more of an appellate argument
and if he's convicted we will definitely
see that being brought up again
but as for today in this trial this will
not
uh work as a dismissal argument for him
i mean it kind of makes sense i hope
that we would never have to think about
a law where we'd be punishing
a governor or a mayor for poisoning
their their residents and their citizens
but
here we are in 2021 one being tried for
that very fact
thank you both coming up on law on crime
daily what's next in a deadly road rage
incident investigators are saying
was racially motivated plus a peek into
the shocking assault of a driver
and the video that captured it all on
the a e network's newest hit series
you don't want to miss this
and we're back video from inside a lift
ride captured a passenger
attacking the driver host of the new a e
series gio benitez is here to explain
who was telling the truth and who was
lying
palm coast florida this driver is on a
seemingly normal ride
in the back seat are three passengers
two men one of whom has a seven-year-old
son with them
they are not all visible you installed
it yourself
yeah really
the driver has placed a plastic
partition to protect everyone from the
kovid 19 virus
but his passenger refuses to believe the
driver put up the barrier himself
i think you're a liar how did you get
this
i paid 25 yeah now you now you put a
light on
now you put a light up
the back door is open and beeping you
open the door
me no nobody's live
open open the door
the two men in the back scheme something
[Music]
[Music]
geo all right so there was a lie and a
truth can you kind of tell us a little
background about that who's lying what
was the lie
what's going on here yeah you know so
these guys get into this car
and automatically you know that this
driver he knows something's wrong
because they keep
asking about this plastic partition and
by the way you see how recent this
is because this is now you know covered
19 right and that's why that
that partition uh was there and so this
driver realizes something's going on
and so he decides to turn on that light
why he knows that dash cam is recording
and he wants to make sure that you could
actually see their faces
there in that video and so he doesn't
say why he's turning on that light
but we all kind of know what's going on
there and then they start
tearing that down and attacking him and
that's just like shocking because
the whole point of the partition is to
protect himself
against covid19 if someone is back there
and they might have the virus and he
doesn't want to get it
that's why that's there now they're
taking it down and now they're grabbing
it
and of course i'm assuming the police
get involved the reports are made
one person is telling one story another
person telling another story and this
video
i guess it's a lyft driver so they have
their video this is telling the truth
and you're
showing us this video as well as reports
from the driver right we're going to
hear from the driver
oh you're going to hear everything from
the driver i mean this
this particular case and by the way it's
not the only
ride share crime that we are capturing
on this show
you know what some of these drivers go
through it's pretty unreal
make sure to check out i survive the
crime errors wednesday at 9 00 pm
eastern on the a e networks
when we come back our illegal take on
sexual harassment claims against new
york's governor
could there be civil or criminal charges
coming exclusive analysis
after the break
welcome back lady gaga's dog walker is
expected to recover after being shot by
two men
who stole two of the pop singer's
pooches
ryan fisher posted on instagram for the
first time since the shooting
saying the love that i feel from around
this planet is immense and intense
he later added that he is grateful that
koji and gustav were returned
according to the lapd the french
bulldogs were found by a good samaritan
who is believed to be uninvolved in the
dog napping officials are still
searching for the two suspects
they are believed to be between 20 and
25 years old anyone with information as
to their whereabouts
are encouraged to call the police
the case of a massachusetts man accused
of murder following a deadly road rage
incident
is heading to a grand jury dean capsalis
is being held without bail
after belmont police say he yelled
racial slurs and hit a man with his
truck
henry tapia died from his injuries not
long after the incident
witnesses say the two men were seen
pulling over to the side of the road
and getting into an angry dispute caps
alice is due back in court
on march 31st
three women have come forward with
accusations of sexual harassment against
new york's governor andrew cuomo
terry austin explains what possible
civil litigation he could be facing
brian new york's attorney's general's
office is launching an independent
investigation into the claims
those findings are expected to be made
public
the women say the governor made unwanted
sexual advances
one aide who worked for cuomo is
claiming cuomo forcibly kissed her
without consent another woman who worked
for cuomo
claims that cuomo asked her about having
sex
with older men a third woman claims that
cuomo touched her back at a wedding
and asked if he could kiss her if the
woman who formerly worked for cuomo
decided to file a claim they would begin
the process by filing a claim
with the equal employment opportunity
commission the eeoc
would then conduct an investigation and
issue
a right to sue letter if warranted
according to the eeoc
harassment can include unwelcome sexual
advances
and other verbal or physical conduct of
a sexual nature
attorney deborah katz is representing
accuser charlotte bennett
katz also represented christine blasey
ford doing brett kavanaugh's supreme
court
confirmation hearings thanks terry
back with us one last time is dina dahl
dina the investigation will be made
public is
is that rare and what do you expect
we'll find in that report
based on what you've heard so far you
know there's actually a statutory
investigative tool that they are filing
this investigation over
so no it is not rare in this instance
there will be a public report after a
very thorough investigation in which we
will see
most likely cuomo himself be deposed and
it's a little bit unclear as of today
what we're going to see
i think it depends if other women come
forward
because as you know here this attorney
who's representing the victim
kind of welcomed any other victims to
come forward
is this just the beginning is this the
end
that i think will depend a lot on what
is uncovered here by the attorney
general
yeah of course we've seen these types of
cases where one or two women make
allegations
and that gives power or strength to
others to come forward so got to keep an
eye on that
terry if this investigation comes back
that nothing happened we'd expect
business as usual i i guess but what if
the claims come back substantiated what
then
you know if the claims are substantiated
i think you're going to see
ramifications
in criminal court and civil court and
actually i think you're going to see
ramifications in the court of public
opinion if you are in criminal court you
know he could
face possible sexual assault claims
obviously if he's in
criminal court or rather if he's in
civil court he could
face sexual harassment claims as i
explained earlier
and as far as public opinion is
concerned he might
actually be asked to step down we've
already
seen the fact that some democrats are
asking him to consider it right now so
if
any of these claims are substantiated he
might have to step down
i mean could this also terry not be a
reason for he get for him getting
impeached if these claims are
substantiated yet alone he's found
guilty right
that's right he could go through an
impeachment process and then we'll see a
trial
for the impeachment so he's really
facing claims
every which way all right dina terry
thank you very much and thank you for
joining us here
on law and crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss justice
in america
[Music]
[Music]
you